what's good everybody my name is alchemy
welcome to the channel today the video
is about making your chords and your
melodies more interesting via sound
design approach i am not very reversed
especially in comparison to a special
someone i know that i'm staring at right
now but at the same time i have a couple
of tricks up my sleeve to help make your
chord progressions or your melodies more
alive and less kind of like stagnant
because there's nothing more
embarrassing than writing out a chord
progression and it just sounds super
boring in general so let's take a look
at a couple of these and while we're
doing that be sure to hit the subscribe
button because you've got nothing else
to do if you're watching this video and
let's take a look at this choir that
i've made
[Music]
now the chords are nothing to write home
about per se but what makes this so
interesting is actually a very simple
trick which is using modulation to
use over a filter to make the chords
seem more interesting or make them seem
like they're quote unquote evolving over
time now this patch is incredibly simple
it's literally just a saw wave with some
detuning and some detuned oh there's no
unison on this and just a choir sample
with a filter and some delay and if you
take the filter off of this look at how
much of a difference this makes
[Music]
it's pretty boring
but going back and adding the filter
[Music]
makes a huge difference in making the
entire sound seem more ethereal and so
my advice to you on this particular
sense is if you've got a chord
progression and it seems a little bit
boring try adding some kind of lfo or a
multi-stage envelope or something that
changes or even thinking about something
in a rhythmic pattern to help make that
chord kind of flesh out and seem more
lustrous in that way
now the other thing that we want to talk
about is something i debated on actually
making a separate video about but i
wanted to take a look over here at this
part of the project because this
arpeggiator right here or arpeggio
rather has a lot of interesting movement
and there's a lot of pieces to this that
make it move so let's go ahead and take
a listen to that
[Music]
now there's a few things that are making
this work for one if you just take a
look at the midi rule here you can see
that it's just a one two three a four
beat
melody
that doesn't really do a whole lot and
it's the same exact doesn't change at
all whatsoever but what does change are
a few things for one i have this
arpeggiator here that is actually
something that again i was thinking
about making a separate video over but
i'll cover in this the arpeggiator
within bitwig is incredible because of
this little feature right here which is
the human eyes and to make a long story
short this will push the individual
notes a little bit late or a little bit
early and add an imperfect swing to your
arpeggiator that seems more natural but
also a lot more groovy in that sense so
if you were trying to come up with a
melody or something that maybe it seems
like you have the notes right but the
the feel or the vibe of it just quite
isn't clicking i would highly recommend
that you throw an arpeggiator on here
and you know you can do all the other
stuff with changing the transposition
and all that but just adding swing
especially for halftime music will go a
long way and then the other thing that
i've done is i have added an octave here
so that way it sounds like it's going
doom
i know that wasn't correct but as
opposed to just this
[Music]
so you can see how much work that
arpeggiator in itself is doing to give
this way more interest and make it
actually seem like it's grooving with
the rest of the track
[Music]
now the last thing that i want to
discuss is the idea about creating
variations in creating fills and there's
a few different ways to do that for one
bit wig is amazing because you are able
to manipulate both midi and audio on the
same track via the hybrid tracks so if
you have something that you want to do
for a fill per se just like this you can
see that this is in midi and then i
bounced this out into audio and just did
a couple of quick glitch cuts right here
and that kind of helps set in the reset
the rhythm rather and then what i did to
make that a little bit more cheeky was i
added the next piece of this which is
the macros and the modulators now face
plan is an amazing tool for this but you
can do this in just about anything but
what i've done is i've mapped
very basic
changes to the sound via these macros
here so one of them controls how much an
octave plays one of them controls how
much a reverb comes in one of them
controls a filter one of them controls
the detuning
all that and the like and so what you're
able to do is kind of pick this out and
draw these in specific sections of this
as you can see here via just clicking on
all these
that allow you to do very basic
automation but changes the sound over
time literally so instead of it just
being
like if you have something that's catchy
and this is something that i've learned
from eprom and i there's a video out on
the internet where he talks about this
but if you've got a catchy rhythm or a
catchy riff
you can create very basic
variations from that by
automating an effect of it over time you
know that way you have something that
still has a familiarity within whatever
it is that you're playing but it creates
more interest because it's emphasizing
that right because it's like here's the
idea now here it is again but in a
different coat of paint and when you
combine that with adding maybe you know
more rhythmic sections or other small
changes with that then the tune is still
pushing forward without you having to
write you know like another melody or
another completely different section
it's just kind of what i would describe
as elaboration
so within that these are just a couple
of things that you can do there's way
more that we could talk about in the
future but for the sake of efficiency
that's what i pretty much have for you
guys today be sure to like and subscribe
consider becoming a member if you want
access to the vods or the master classes
that i've got coming out and i'll see
the next one